[Applause]
I'm just with Jane for the funnest game
show ever okay I never will wait we've
all been on how the game not a lot of us
here but actually if you have you all
have been on Dancing with the Stars
I've given up dancing is that what you
like I just think people understand how
brutal that show is oh no it looks like
that oh yeah god forbid they do the
picture of the dance when I was in a
tuxedo no no we want to embarrass you
yeah they'll vouch for this is that the
thing that was the weirdest for me was
if you got moved forward there was no
like I'll see you in a couple days it
was the next morning you were back in
this dance hall yeah I figured out when
I left that show when I got in limonade
in the finals that I had danced six
hours a day seven days a week for 13
weeks Wow now yeah you an incredible
shade no no I was and I was I won't say
my age but it was in the high 50s when I
did it men my age see their young then
my age aren't designed to dance six
hours a day seven days a week for 13
weeks
we're designed to dance once a year
drunk at a wedding if you hear that I'm
doing Dancing with the Stars you know
there's something really wrong
absolutely I can't I hate to dance I
hate people telling me how to move my
body because I can't do it that'd be a
big joke that's what the best part of it
because I kept getting moved forward and
what I always think it's funny is if you
go back in Google the dancers don't even
watch the dance just go to the when they
take all those scores out and look at
the judges face every time we got moved
forward they had this look like how is
he
but it's fan voted it's fan voter and it
and I had a blast
Emma a little Emma Slater was my partner
and I would never ever do it again in 13
weeks I tore my groin pulled my
hamstring and had to have my knee
replace Wow and I say no sir to that man
nope nope so you're you're touring
though and you're doing last-minute
standing with Tim Allen that show it's
great right we have so much fun yeah
yeah are you having such a good time
yeah I play a character called Reverend
Paul that's kind of become a reoccurring
character and and he's Reverend Paul is
probably the only guy that can say
things to Mike Baxter that nobody else
can say because he's in the clergy yeah
but it's a it's been interesting it's
like kind of like with the Dancing with
the Stars it oh I'm on the road now
people are you do another Last Man
Standing it's amazing the popularity job
it's a great show it's a great show yeah
so hopefully they'll give me a lot more
yeah subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going